just looking at this I can see how the
light infomercial will come together are
you tired of like spilling what's up
guys I'm Nietzsche I'm a tasty producer
and I'm going to be testing the pasta
and more device as seen on TV I'll be
trying to figure out if it works if the
food tastes good and if it's worth
buying let's make some pasta looking at
it it seems like an S seen on TV product
this little image right here looks like
a iron end to me and it looks like a
crock pot shout out my homeboy chef Tony
he looks like a guy that likes
microwavable pasta the box has spaghetti
my parents made spaghetti like all my
life just like spaghetti and catfish
those are like go-to things so this is
gonna be fun so this thing is also
supposed to have like a measure on it so
you can get the perfect amount of pasta
so I'm hoping I can make like one
serving or two serving and actually get
it right it's supposed to be two steps
microwave and strain seems a little
weird there's no scientific information
on here as to how this seemingly copper
but also see-through device is going to
work this is what this side of the box
is dedicated to the and more comment
below if you'd like to see us make any
more
[Music]
this is straight plastic a little birdie
told me that putting plastic in a
microwave is not something that I should
do but chef Tony says it's great though
all right we got some instructions in
here quick and easy recipes today we're
just focusing on pasta feels like part
of the Easy Bake Oven you open it up oh
this slides off
these look like handles they don't look
very like heat proof but I think this is
also how you measure the spaghetti it
seems like a pretty simple device Oh
storage lid so if you like make your
pasta in here and instead of having to
like condense it to another like
Tupperware crank this baby on there so I
guess that also means you're serving
this and you're putting this on your
dinner table which is fine to each his
own I honestly am not extremely
optimistic about the texture that we're
gonna get in this let's get some pasta
in here and find out
[Music]
all right so here are steps cooking
pasta insert the spaghetti into the
handle and measure two servings of pasta
okay let's make two servings of pasta
okay this looks like it's supposed to be
two servings so let's see if their
measurements are right there
I think the handle thing is supercool
this looks this looks like one serving I
don't know our next step is to remove
the strainer lid in the steaming rack
when cooking the pasta that's in red
that seems real important let's place
our pasta inside of the container boom
perfect fit okay so it says here in the
chart for two servings you need a water
level of two in one handle so I already
have my one handle I got my two servings
let's put up to the water level or two
this is about right there the pasta now
our next step is you must leave open
when cooking pasta apparently that's
really important place pasta and more in
the microwave and cook high for 18 to 20
minutes I don't know about you guys but
usually when I'm using something in the
microwave I want it to go quicker let's
put this in a microwave for 18 to 20
minutes
[Music]
okay here we are with some pasta nice
and steamy we let her go for 18 minutes
you can just pull it out it wasn't hot
at all
nothing has melted it looks like we've
held our shape carefully slide the
strainer lid onto the boat boom I can
like kind of lift that body lid so that
lets me know it's not gonna like pop off
the instructions for straining say close
the other half of the lid which we've
done make sure the strainer is perfectly
secure which it is and then tilt to
drain the water into the sink serve
pasta with sauce or butter enjoy alright
here we go
slice and easy
the width feels extremely secure we're
gonna try and plate this let's see
what's happening this looks like the
kind of like texture like I would have
I'm actually fairly impressed
there aren't any burnt tips at the top
like the water and it boiled down too
much nice and easy it's it's nonstick -
so let's top this with some tasty
marinara sauce what is pasta without
cheese let's add some basil on area
we've got some full basil leaves just as
like a little garnish I think chef Tony
would be like oh wow
[Music]
all right this is looking absolutely
beautiful I'm pretty excited to try this
let's go in for a bite mm-hmm that's
actually really good I like a nice bite
to it you know and this is like kind of
perfectly al dente so I'm super
impressed with that and the only con I'd
say it was probably cracked it takes 18
to 20 minutes to cook in the microwave
it measured out perfect leave nothing
was burnt nothing was dry perfect
texture so a on that I think you could
probably get the same like texture on
the stove and it probably taken you the
same amount of time but this actually
works cleanup is super easy this is
dishwasher safe we paid about 16 bucks
for this value super great if you live
in a dorm you don't have a stovetop this
is the product that you need chef tony
was looking out for the college students
with this one and all of my studio
bachelors out there based on how this
tastes and the way that it works I'm
very surprised on saying this but it's
all a thumbs-up chef Tony you did that
thing bro so that's it for the pasta in
more very surprised it went really well
this is actually pretty good product let
us know if there are any other products
that you guys want us to review I'm
gonna go finish my two servings of
spaghetti by myself later guys oh yes
[Music]